mario paul is a city almost completely
destroyed and from where thousands of
civilians have been unable to escape
the last major battle is happening here
at a giant soviet-built factory in an
industrial district the remainings of
the ukrainian army and large group of
civilians are basically uh
encircled by the russian forces they
continue their struggle
but uh it seems from the way russian
army behaves in mariupol
they decided to raise the city to the
ground at any cost
bodies lie on the streets in the
besieged port city ukrainian forces
ignored a russian ultimatum to surrender
by 1pm local time on sunday ukraine's
prime minister says its forces will
fight to the end
the outcome will likely affect talks to
resolve the war the presidentiations are
probably going to go in the opposite
direction after russia captures
marryable because zelensky has made it
very clear that if russia carries that
another massacre in mariopol that's
comparable to what we saw in bucha on
the remaining forces then there'll be
basically a dead stop for negotiations
the ukrainian foreign minister said that
there's really been no dialogue between
ukraine and russia over the past 48
hours
russia's onslaught continues elsewhere
in the east
this is the aftermath of yet another
russian missile strike in hakeef this
mainly russian-speaking city ukraine's
second largest has suffered some of the
worst shelling since russia's invasion
more than seven weeks ago
paramedics treat the injured but the
danger isn't over yet
ukraine says russia has stepped up its
attacks in the region as its forces
prepare for a new offensive in the east
but president zielenski says he remains
steadfast in his determination not to
concede any territory
victoria gatenbee al jazeera